[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans les 7 8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
rugby plaisir à réaliser la bonne
opération de ce week-end en fédérale 3
les joueurs de jean miss se sont imposés
contre le deuxième ris orangis avec la
manière le résumé tu as eue dans
quelques instants
toujours en rugby le club de versailles
vient de lancer une section de rugby à 5
un créneau vient d'être créé le samedi
matin dans la structure quinze personnes
se sont déjà inscrits pour participer à
l'entraînement plus de détails dans
cette émission basket pascal lucky 33
ans vient de signer dans son club
formateur l'as montigny-le-bretonneux le
sportif revient au club pour remporter
le titre le pré régionale cette saison
son portrait dans ce magazine
gros plan à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end
[Musique]
c'est sans doute le plus bel exploit de
ce week-end pour le sport évinois en
fédérale 3 de rugby à plaisir deuxième
du classement s'est offert le leader
invaincu à ris orangis sur son terrain
avec cette victoire de prestige les
plaisirs hoa terminent la phase aller un
premier du classement
retour sur ce match les images sont
signés à nicolas doré le rugby-club de
plaisir a réussi à faire tomber le
leader invaincu ris orangis à domicile
pourtant ce choc entre le premier et le
deuxième de fédérale 3 avait très mal
débuté pour les challengers yvelinois
avec un 10 à 0 au bout de 13 minutes de
jeu
décrispés d'enlever au début du match on
a eu du mal à rentrer dans le match et
on était quand même assez crispé au
départ et après mais effectivement ça
c'est un petit peu débloquer ensuite on
prend un essai un peu casquette qui
vainquit nommé à dix points à 10 0 après
ce premier quart d'heure difficile
plaisir s'est accroché a réussi à
inscrire deux essais avant la pause pour
mener 15 à 10 à la mi-temps
[Musique]
au retour des vestiaires les illilois
concède un deuxième essai une claque qui
a boosté les jaunes et bleus les joueurs
de jean me sont élever leur niveau de
jeu pour ajouter trois essayé d'emporter
32 à 17,5 de soulagement parce que c'est
une très belle équipe on a perdu deux
fois contre l'année dernière et puis ils
sont devant au classement il fallait
absolument qu'on gagne ce match pour
pouvoir recoller et continue et
continuer la saison avec l'objectif
toujours d'essayer de finir à la
première place
objectif rempli à la mi-saison avec
cette victoire avec le bonus offensif
plaisir termine premier de la phase
aller avec 38 points une longueur devant
son adversaire du jour
comme quoi être que satisfait de ce
bilan avec une seule défaite
hamon et voilà qu'en après l'échec la
seconde partie belle sera pas évident
non plus et ont conduit à travailler
pour obtenir une deux de ses deux
premières places plaisir peut désormais
savourer sa première place pendant le
long mois et demi de trêve hivernale le
club reprendra la compétition le 15
janvier contre viry châtillon toujours
en rugby si tout va bien pour plaisir le
sky rugby est lui aussi en bonne posture
dans le championnat de promotion
d'honneur
les hommes de thomas payet en réalisé le
gros coup de cette huitième journée en
remportant le derby contre rambouillet
sur le score de 24 à 5
au classement les saint quentinois
repasse premier devant chilly mazarin
avec un bilan de six victoires et une
défaite depuis le début de la saison les
événements reprendront le 15 janvier
prochain sur leur terrain contre noisy
le sec
on reste dans le monde de l'ovalie c'est
nouveau une section de rugby à 5
surnommé également le rugby à toucher
vient à de s'ouvrir pas que dans le club
de versailles la structure créée en 1893
a mis en place un créneau le samedi
matin pour développer cette discipline
pratiquée par plus de 200 clubs dans
l'hexagone
romero spinea pour le montage du rugby
sont les bobos c'est la promesse de
cette formule à cinq joueurs ces
disciplines qui compte plus de 2500
licenciés à travers la france est en
pleine expansion depuis deux ans pour
surfer sur cette dynamique le rugby-club
de versailles a ouvert un créneau mixte
le samedi matin en octobre dernier nous
a personne a voulu créer cette élection
parce qu'on trouve que ça d'intérêt
pratique en tout cas d'attirer les
filles vers le rugby puisque n'arrive
pas à l'inversé a tiré les cheveux et
rugby et puis c'est sympa de retrouver
des d'attirer des débutants et aussi
dans des 100 sièges joueurs qui ont joué
avant canet mardi contact et du coup qui
retrouve maintenant le plaisir du ballon
ovale en vente ici les règles développé
par la fédération française de rugby
sont simples les plaquages sont
interdits le jeu est arrêté dès que le
joueur est touché des deux mains par un
adversaire comme ça que c'est vraiment
jeu d'évitement un jeu de rapidité
l'objectif est de rigueur 5 prend de
vitesse son adversaire à puteaux va
prendre lutte est l'adversaire notamment
sur les relances de jeu après le touché
plus ça va être simple de d'aller
marquer passages vraiment un jeu de
traite pas très technique mais technique
puisqu'il faut savoir faire des longues
parce qu'on a 50 matin j'irai à cinq
depuis la création de la section loisirs
15 joueurs débutants ou confirmés deux
ou trois fils sont inscrits il ya une
ambiance sympa c'est un jeu quoi c'est
plus c'est peut-être moins solennelle
que le rugby a qu'un c'est ce qu'on sait
qu'à trois singes tout le monde peut
participer les filles et les garçons les
jeunes et moins jeunes
c'est physique il faut se dépenser on
peut pas y aller à moitié il faut juste
s'y mettre avoir de la bonne volonté et
puis appuie la pratique bien le rugby
club de versailles espère at-il entre 40
et 50 licenciés d'ici deux ans et
participer à des compétitions régionales
dans les prochaines années
on ouvre à présent une page voile dans
ce magazine avec le vendée globe 2016
deux événements affronte en ce moment
les vagues et les vents dans ce tour du
monde en solitaire un peu plus de 9000
kilomètres de notre studio a eu recours
en polythène louis burton sur son imoca
bureau vallée pour le moment 11e de la
course à un peu plus de 3000 milles
nautiques du leader armel le cléac'h sur
banque populaire
le navigateur à yvelinois n'a pas
beaucoup dormi ces derniers jours le
skipper a dû réparer son safran
endommagé avec du carbone nous présente
sa recette pour gérer sa fatigue
il n'y a pas vraiment de cycle 2
journées dans la journée calme ou pas
calme
disons que c'est vraiment lié à la météo
il ya une allure qui est relativement
tranquille c'est le travers dans la
brise parce que ça permet de le bateau
le bateau est plutôt stable va vite et
donc bon même si ça tapait que ça bouge
beaucoup ça permet de se reposer parce
qu'on perd pas trop de temps en se
reposant quelques milles nautiques
derrière louis burton on retrouve le
versailles et éric bellion l'yvelinois
est pour le moment la 20e place du
classement et tente lui aussi de dormir
le plus possible pour récupérer
il a enregistré cette vidéo ce week-end
je suis dans ma table à cartes contre
nous et j'espère poser sa tête
trois jours que
pas très bien je suis vraiment fatigué
les grains succèdent
c'est vraiment le monde difficile moi
j'accuse le coup très clairement
très spécial
parce que sa maman je dois accepter le
fait que
fatigué et ce qui compte c'est de nous
reposer parce que si je mets
plus de toile pour aller plus vite je
vais casser quelque chose je vais vous
blesser
tout cas c'est pas l'objectif du projet
de son côté le versailles et tanguy de
lamotte et lui aussi rêver aux sablons
est arrivé aux sables d'olonne
aujourd'hui le skipper d'initiative
coeur a dû abandonner le 15 novembre
suite à une avarie
après avoir tenté de réparer son mât il
a dû se résoudre à arrêter la course au
large du cap vert
le navigateur est revenu au port sans
assistance ont péri pour a permis de
sauver plus de 35 enfants atteints de
problèmes cardiaques
grâce à son site internet retour sur la
terre ferme avec le championnat de
basket montigny le bretonneux s'est
incliné de justesse à l'extérieur ce
week-end sur le terrain de la celle
saint cloud une défaite 56 à 51 qui
plombe le très bon début de saison de
l'équipe lésigny monter un redescendre à
la 6e place avec un match en moins et
deux points de retard sur le premier
abeilles et noisy prochain match pour
montigny le week-end prochain contre
jouy en josas samedi à 20h30
on reste sur les parcs et de
montigny-le-bretonneux l'équipe senior
de basket a enregistré à leur tour de
pascal qui est un joueur de haut niveau
formé au club dans sa jeunesse il sera
le leader technique de l'équipe cette
saison le montage est signée à pascal
josèphe montigny le bretonneux a
enregistré le retour d'un enfant du club
pascal lucky 33 ans passé par versailles
quand on entre fréjus et le canada
décidé de revenir dans son club de coeur
une structure qui l'a vu réaliser ses
premiers dribbles et ses premiers
paniers à trois points aux poussins à
l'âge de 10 ans je pense qu'à un moment
donné quand tu as fait beaucoup clubs
différents août avait des objectifs
aussi bien sportif que personnel voilà
revenir à quelque chose vous
je joue vraiment avec des amis c'est une
sensation différente et moi c'est
vraiment ce que je voulais ressentir
cette année j'avais des possibilités de
partir dans boot l'homme mais vraiment
dans la revenir aux meneurs chez moi et
jouer avec vos amis donc arrivé avec un
statut de joueur d'expérience pascal leu
qui a réalisé un début de saison
tonitruant avec une moyenne de 15 points
5 passes et 5 rebonds par match
lenny mantin s'épanouit à son poste
d'arrière à l'image de ses idoles moi je
suis né en quatre ans un poids donc j'ai
grandi avec la génération jordan cagoule
et settat donc voilà c'est vraiment le
premier sportive on va dire qu'il m'a
dit m'a inspiré après derrière fait lui
qui ressemblait le plus à ce qu'il
faisait c'était kobe bryant et voilà qu
big aussi au moins fait les deux joueurs
qui sont uniques et non j'aime beaucoup
c'est moins inspiré d'un jeu dans la
manière d'être dans le leadership est
tous sur le plan collectif son arrivée
coïncide avec le renouveau de montigny
le bretonneux l'équipe en difficulté
depuis plusieurs saisons occupent les
premières places du championnat
prérégional avec un bilan de cinq
victoires et deux défaites
vu qu'il a joué dans un niveau supérieur
et il connaît déjà pour réussir et koné
les clés naturellement c'est un joueur
de
de bons niveaux de haut niveau donc dans
les moments clés dans les matches qui
sera assez vite y est là pour remettre
le shoot qui peut faire la différence
le fait de revenir au club voilà nous
fait un gros plus sur le terrain et en
dehors du terrain aussi tout ce qui est
conseils pour y aider un peu les voir
après avoir remis avec ses coéquipiers
montigny sur les rails pascal leu qui
espère ramener le titre en fin de saison
et guider l'équipe vers les portes de la
nationale dans les deux à trois
prochaines années
une journée sportive sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines la
structure a accueilli pour la première
fois depuis 2003 un cross départemental
unss mercredi après midi
plus de 2500 jeunes âgés de 13 à 18 ans
participer à l'événement au total dix
courses à pied en pleine nature de deux
à quatre kilomètres c'était programmé
on écoute l'une des organisatrices
alexandra à sa manette alors c'est un
gros événement puisqu'il rassemble plus
de 2500 élèves sur tout le département
des yvelines non classés 92 à 100
établissements qui sont concernés on a
autant des établissements du coin c'est
à dire des établissements de maurepas
trappe voisin gros tonneau que des
établissements qui viennent de mantes la
jolie où de rambouillet l'objectif du
cross départemental ans un championnat
départemental
ça veut dire qu'il est qualificatif pour
le championnat académique qui lui sera
qualificatif au championnat de france
on passe maintenant à notre rubrique
agenda
un combat qu'il ne faudra pas manquer si
vous êtes un fan de boxe le verrier roi
ahmed el moussaoui 26 ans affrontera
l'espagnol assez ferino rodrigues pour
le titre vacant de champion d'europe ebu
des poids welters le combat est
programmée ce vendredi à las palmas sur
les îles canaries
déjà champion de france est détenteur de
la championne ceinture de l'union
européenne le saint quentinois sera le
favori de la rencontre européenne de
saint quentinois sera donc sur les rings
ce vendredi on termine à part du
football et la coupe gambardella les
clayes-sous-bois joueront ce dimanche à
14h30 sur leur teint contre caen au
stade beltramini à l'occasion du 6e tour
de la compétition les clés siens
l'avaient emporté est le 13 novembre
dernier 3 1 contre clichy sur seine au
tour précédent une équipe qui évolue
pourtant deux divisions au dessus
la rencontre est programmée à ce
week-end et elle sera évidemment à série
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
fil 78
[Musique]